chaos in zeiten des corona virus meint
chaos in
zeitlosigkeit einer schiebt den anderen
die verantwortung zu derweil das virus
sein glück kaum fassen kann und sich
ausbreitet je länger dieser zustand
andauert umso härter muss die staatliche
gegenwehr sein die wiederum gegen wir
erzeugen wird
rekordwerte hilft nur die impfpflicht
jetzt in der führungsrunde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist christine
vogel präsidentin des deutschen
pflegerats vertreten die pflegerinnen
und pfleger in den krankenhäusern und
den altenheimen ebenfalls im studio eva
quadbeck
stellvertretende chefredakteurin und
leiterin des hauptstadtbüros des
redaktions netzwerks deutschland das ist
ein zusammenschluss mehrerer
zeitungstitel
zugeschaltet ist uns das sind uns aus
hamburg von der universität hamburg der
virologe professor jonas
schmidt-chanasit
und der staatsrechtler professor
christian pestalozza ist bei uns sie
sind neben der funktion staatsrechtler
zu sein auch mitglied in zwei
ethikkommissionen hier im land berlin
des landes berlin und der berliner
ärztekammer frau kurt beck von ihnen
stammt der satz
gefährlich wird es wenn sich corona
politik mit parteibuch verbindet da
haben wir eigentlich zukunft nichts
gutes zu erwarten
im moment sieht man das ja ganz klar
dass die
ampel parteien in der opposition vor
allen dingen die fdp gesagt haben wir
wollen die pandemische notlage beenden
das war damals auch ja sehr stark aus
der opposition heraus da die
gegenposition gegen den mainstream
einzunehmen und aus der nummer kommen
sie jetzt nicht mehr so richtig raus und
wider alle vernunft und jetzt die
pandemische notlage beendet obwohl wir
wie sie es gerade gesagt haben ja
wirklich auf dem auf einem höhepunkt
dieser pandemie angekommen sind und wenn
man in die krankenhäuser guckt dann hat
man ein ziemlich heftiger notlage im
moment da sitzt sie sagen ja die
ungeimpften seien eine relativ kleine
gruppe also kein großes problem vielmehr
müssten jetzt die so genannten variablen
gruppen also alte und kranke besser
geschützt und vor allem gepustet werden
also mit einer dritten impfung versehen
ist die öffentliche diskussion die
gerade anhebt für sie viel lärm um fast
nichts
nein das sicherlich nicht und ich habe
auch gesagt dass die zahl der
ungeimpften die man ohne impfpflicht
noch aus man kann wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr groß sein wird und darum ist es
wichtig die begrenzten ressourcen die
wir in deutschland haben dort
einzusetzen wo wir sehr viele menschen
in kurzer zeit erreichen können und das
sind eben gerade wie von erst die
krämpfe holen die booster impfung bei
den über 70-jährigen frau vogler warum
ist ausgerechnet beim pflegepersonal die
impfquote nicht so hoch wie sie
eigentlich sein sollte das sind ja
menschen die als pflegende arbeiten die
mit gerade diesen variablen gefährdeten
gruppen jeden tag kontakt haben wir
müssen erstmal unterscheiden dass es
hält sich hartnäckig das gerücht dass
die pflegenden sich impfen lassen wollen
das stimmt so nicht wir haben in den
kliniken nach die impfquote ist nicht so
wie sie sein sollte ja sie ist bei 90
prozent in den kliniken das kann man auf
den rk ii seiten nachlesen das ist auch
eine valide zahl und da liegen wir 25
prozent über dem normalen schnitt fehlen
immer noch zehn muss man deutlich sagen
wir haben in den bereichen der langzeit
versorgung also der heime keine validen
zahlen aber wir haben da auch nicht so
viele fachkräfte sondern da wird oft
nicht gewusst dass in dem pflegeheim wie
in fachkraftquote schlüssel haben und
dass man arbeiten maximal 50 prozent
fachkräfte und eben viele ungelernte und
viele angelernte und ich denke da müssen
wir hin schauen und müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir hier noch mal nachsteuern und
wir haben ja auch gesagt eine
impfpflicht unterstützen wir nicht aber
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
darüber müssen wir nach man könnte ja
die angelernten auch darauf hinweist
dass es vielleicht sinnvoll ist sich
impfen zu lassen wird gemacht aber wir
merken dass es da schwieriger ist
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten der
pestalozzi die impfpflicht die
allgemeine oder die teilweise
impfpflicht die wird ja schon länger
gefordert die dynamik dieser diskussion
gibt ja jetzt gerade richtig an die
gegner der impf ich sagen ja die
grundrechte würden massiv eingeschränkt
werden durch eine impfpflicht sind wir
denn schon an den punkt an dem eine
impfpflicht zwingend geboten ist
also der hängt der jurist in seiner
beurteilung natürlich ab von dem was die
fachleute von einem mediziner sagen
wenn
ich sehe dass wir genügend impfstoff
haben dass die quote der impf nicht
relativ groß ist und dass die korona
zahlen in die höhe gehen dann spricht
doch alles dafür eine nebenpflicht sein
spektiv sprung sei es allgemein
einzuführen wenn alles andere nicht
zügig hilft und unabhängig davon ab wann
die impfpflicht greift in der einen oder
anderen form muss die politik sich
hinsetzen egal ob eine neue regierung
schon steht oder nicht und eine solche
impfpflicht gesetzgeberisch vorbereiten
so dass sowie die notlage akuter wird
und die medizin für einen pflicht
plädiert das gesetz in kraft treten kann
man kann nicht die hände so lange in den
schoß legen bis es wirklich zeit ist zu
dem letzten mittel zu greifen dann fängt
man an ein gesetz vorzubereiten das
vielleicht wochen braucht um den kraft
zu treten
wenn man das jetzt hört vor kurt beck
sieht es ja auch gerade schon die
politische situation geschildert es gibt
ja diesen verbalen running gag von
konrad adenauer die lage ist ernst aber
nicht hoffnungslos ja wie ernst ist sie
denn eigentlich vor allen dingen wenn
man sich jetzt überlegt das ja einiges
geschehen muss die pandemische notlage
soll auslaufen es gibt jetzt ein neues
gesetz das die ampel koalition wohl noch
nicht offiziell im amt einer koalition
jetzt durch den bundestag bringen wird
wie ist diese situation im moment jetzt
auch gerade in der beide an einem tag wo
er sich nicht nur die intention erhöht
haben runder die zahl der neu
infizierten sich innerhalb von 24
stunden fast verdoppelt hat also wir
erleben eigentlich so was ähnliches wie
im vergangenen herbst wieder dass
nämlich die politik überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet ist auf diese situation in
diesem jahr ist das noch schwieriger
weil durch die bundestagswahl überhaupt
ganz unklar war was sven gemacht
konstellation ist dann hinterher geben
wird und dann ist es so dass zumindest
bislang immer noch ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen abgehalten wurden wo
manchmal unsinn beschlossen worden ist
wie wir wissen aber wo doch zumindest
man versucht hat leitplanken für die
bundesrepublik und für den umgang mit
dieser corona pandemie zu schaffen und
wo man auch gelernt hat planken zu
schaffen und die region dann durchaus
nach ihren bedürfnissen und nach ihren
instanzen machen zu lassen im moment ist
es ja so schleswig holstein hatten die
inzidenz von etwas über 80 bayern ist
bei fast 400 natürlich braucht es
unterschiedliche reaktionen
aber dass es bisher noch nicht gelungen
ist das wo ist die wurst kanzlerin
merkel wo ist der künftige kanzler olaf
scholz ja dass die es nicht geschafft
haben die länder mal an einen tisch zu
versammeln und auch die spitzen von spd
fdp und grünen mit dazu zu holen das
finde ich wirklich
gefährlich dass das einfach nicht
geschafft ein bisschen einheitliche
regelung die länder sagen ja schließlich
deutschland zum beispiel was
interessiert mich die hohen intelligenz
in bayern bei uns ist alles in bester
ordnung oder jedenfalls wesentlich
besser als im süden des landes die sagen
dann brauchen wir keine
bundeseinheitlichen regelung das habe
ich ja gerade gesagt wir brauchen nicht
einheitlichkeit überall sondern wir
brauchen leitplanken was solche auch ein
versäumnis ist das nicht festgelegt
worden ist bei welcher krankenhaus lage
denn dann was geschieht jetzt in berlin
werden keine planbaren operationen mehr
angenommen berlin macht zweig und auf
bundesebene sagt man wir machen jetzt
für jeden einmal pro woche im test
wieder kostenlos das ist ja total
widersinnig weil wenn zweig ist dann
brauchen die umgebung nicht mehr
klarheit auch auf bundesebene
ja ich bräuchte es bräuchte sowieso wer
klarheit das bräuchte eine klare
strategie im moment herrscht ja quasi
anarchie was corona maßnahmen angeht
herr schmidt chanasit müssen wir denn
diese vierte welle die gerade so über
uns hinweg rollt einfach so hinnehmen
ohne gegenrede müssen wir das jetzt
einfach akzeptieren dass die so über uns
hinweg rollt ist es schon zu spät die
aufzuhalten die zahlen ich hab sie ja
gerade zitiert die neue institution die
stark steigenden incident ziehen
236 menschen sind verstorbenen krone
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden die
zahlen liegen zum teil höher als im
letzten winter wo wir ja schon von einer
katastrophe gesprochen haben sind wir
dieser virtuelle jetzt schutzlos
ausgeliefert müssen sie jetzt einfach
hinnehmen
nein natürlich überhaupt nicht wir haben
viele möglichkeiten in der pandemie
mittel einzusetzen um die ausdruck
dieser pandemie einzudämmen und
natürlich unterscheidet sich die
situation heute grundlegend von der vor
einem jahr weil eben ein großteil der
bevölkerung geimpft ist wir mussten
jetzt in den letzten monaten eben
feststellen dass der schutz vor
infektionen abnimmt dass es auch etwas
unerwartet schnell gekommen und darum
ist es jetzt genau richtig dass wir die
besonders gefährdeten menschen
auffrischen genau das heißt die stiko
empfohlen hat auf der anderen seite ist
es jetzt wichtig dass wir die teste klug
und intelligent an denen stellen
einsetzen wo sie wirklich benötigt
werden dh zum beispiel eine test nicht
in den alten und pflegeheimen im
ambulanten bereich das bringt einfach
eine zusätzliche sicherheit in diesen
bereichen weil wir müssen uns noch mal
vergegenwärtigen dass der größte teil
der korona die ruß verstorbenen eben
diesen bereichen aufgetreten ist und
dort müssen jetzt die begrenzten
ressourcen die wir in deutschland haben
gebündelt werden aber diese
testverfahren waren ja auch durchaus
kritisch zu sehen die schnelltests auf
haben sie nicht funktioniert sind falsch
angewendet worden ist da dass dieses
testen testen testen da wirklich das
allheilmittel
dann müssen wir ins detail gehen da gebe
ich ihnen vollkommen recht ich sage
jetzt mal ganz plakativ der schnelltest
der für 48 stunden in einer besenkammer
durchgeführt wurde der bringt uns nicht
weiter insofern in alten- und
pflegebereich würde ich hier die kugel
pcr test um präferieren eine regelmäßige
testung und natürlich kostenlos und auf
der anderen seite muss man sich
überlegen und das ist aber eine
politische normative frage welche
testsysteme man in weniger gefährdeten
bereichen einsetzt oder ob man dort eben
nicht auf andere maßnahmen masken
abstand setzt weil wir haben ja zum
beispiel es gerade beim karneval
wirklich aberwitzige situationen dort
kommen in großer menge geimpfte und
genießen zusammen aber natürlich kann es
dort auch zu übertragen kommen und zu
infektionen die dann durchaus in
kritische bereiche hinein getragen wenn
also hier die ich mir natürlich
flankierende maßnahmen und auch teste
gewünscht in diesen bereichen was ja in
zukunft wahrscheinlich die länder auch
für sich immer jeweils entscheiden
können möglicherweise auch die kreise
und regionen wenn sie es denn
entscheiden es gibt ja fugel ein
albtraum szenario dass menschen sterben
weil ungeimpfte die intensivstationen
verstopfen was bedeutet das zum beispiel
für pflegerinnen und pfleger in einer
solchen situation erscheint ja ganz kurz
davor zusammen vor der sendung im heute
schnell gesehen aus thüringen einen
bericht 90 prozent der der auf der
intensivstation an schwerer erkrankung
lebensbedrohliche erkrankung dort liegen
das sind ungeimpfte die nehmen könnten
möglicherweise einen aufenthalt
vermeiden wenn sie sich impfen ließen
nehmen anderen
intensivpatienten
notfallpatienten die betten wett was
bedeutet das eigentlich auch für die für
die pflegerinnen und pfleger also das
eine ist natürlich da stoßen wir
natürlich eine ethische diskussion vor
ich glaube da muss uns klar sein dass
wir nicht bewerten wen wir versorgen wer
hilfe braucht wird hilfe bekommen
ungeachtet dessen warum er in dieser
situation ist ich glaube dass daran
werden wir niemals rütteln das ist auch
die haltung der menschen die im
gesundheitsbereich arbeiten wir fragen
ja auch nicht die raucherinnen oder den
leberkranken oder warum menschen in die
situation kommen weil jemand sich
versucht hat sowie zitiert es gibt so
viele fälle wo man diese frage stellen
könnte die stellen wir nicht natürlich
ist es aber so dass die gedanken dahin
gehen dass man sagt mensch warum warum
vermeiden die menschen nicht diese
situation für sich selbst und für die
anderen
die kolleginnen und kollegen sind seit
die sind ja in die panini schon
eingegangen in einer pflegerischen
krisensituation es gab ja schon vor der
pandemie situation so wenig pflegende
und jetzt nach den anderthalb jahre sind
ja fast eindreiviertel jahre ist
überhaupt kein puffer mehr da ist nichts
mehr da wenn jeder der geht reißt ein
riesiges loch und es wird uns in den
nächsten jahren noch beschäftigen und
zwar noch viel mehr als heute im moment
haben wir hier aber einen herrn eine
akute not ist aktion betten sind gleich
geblieben aber viel weniger pflege damit
können wir diese betten nicht mehr
verwenden sie haben es gesagt sie
betrachten ich sag das jetzt mal als das
verursacherprinzip aus ethischer sicht
aber man kann das verursacherprinzip
herr professor pestalozza auch aus
rechtlicher sicht betrachten heute habe
ich eine meldung gelesen dass der
stadtstaat singapur nicht unbedingt eine
demokratie im westlichen sinne jetzt
entschieden hat dass die
koma patientin die ungeimpften cola
patienten ihre behandlung selbst
bezahlen müssen um eben diese
nachlässigkeit entsprechend zu
sanktionieren wäre zumindest eine
beteiligung an solchen kosten auch bei
uns rechtlich möglich
das denke ich schon und finanziellen
lasten werden ja auch jetzt schon den
ohne besonderen grund ungeimpften
auferlegt nicht wenn sie an die
lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall und
quarantäne fall denken
und wenn sich jemand eher impfen lassen
können es aber ohne sachlichen grund
nicht getan hat dann fällt eben diese
fallen diese zuschüsse der länder weg
das ist ja eine ähnliche finanzielle
reaktion aber das wird nicht dazu führen
nehme ich an jedenfalls haben wir noch
keine belege dafür dass in großer zahl
mehr leute sich impfen lassen auch
mehrfach impfen lassen als das bisher
der fall ist als du das wird alleine
nicht ausreichen aber finanzielle
anreize auf der anderen seite für
diejenigen die es impfen lassen und
finanzielle lasten für die ihnen dies
nicht tun das ist auch rechtlich
vertretbar
schmidt chanasit sie haben gerade
aufgezählt was wichtig ist es muss
richtig getestet werden es müssen vor
allen dingen die
empfindlichen die so genannten variablen
gruppen die besonders bedroht sind vom
virus geschützt werden alte und kranke
aber wird das möglicherweise oder genügt
das überhaupt auch wenn wir ja gerade
sehen dass die impfquote stagniert seit
einiger zeit
ihr kollege christian drosten mit denen
sie glaube ich nicht immer einer meinung
sind hat ja heute gefordert man muss
doch wieder über kontakt beschränkungen
nachdenken und vielleicht einen
partiellen lockdown ist das eine
möglichkeit in dem winter dem winter
auch die die zahl der korona erkrankten
wieder einzudämmen sie haben gesagt wir
müssen uns jetzt wir sind dieser vierten
corona welle nicht hilflos ausgeliefert
genau wir sind definitiv dieser vierten
welle nicht hilflos ausgeliefert und
müssen sage ich mal die intelligenten
maßnahmen die wir in deutschland zur
verfügung haben jetzt gezielt einsetzen
und dann denke ich wenn man das mit
aller kraft und vernunft macht dass man
die situation auch kontrollieren kann
und dazu gehört eben dass wir unsere
begrenzten ressourcen nicht um hieß kann
prinzipiell sozusagen verteilen das
heißt wir machen ein museum zu weinen
altenheim zu schützen sondern diese
ressourcen wirklich erst mal gezielt an
den besonders kritischen stellen
einsetzen das fängt beim impfen an dass
wir sagen wir fokussieren uns auch die
eben flüge bei den über 60-jährigen zu
schließen das ist nicht einfach da
stimme ich an westerlo zwar unbedingt zu
gerade wenn wir sehen wer auf den
intensivstationen behandelt wird das
sind bürgerinnen und bürger mit
sprachbarriere die sind nicht gut
erreicht worden und hier ist es
natürlich eine wichtige aufgabe diese
menschen noch besser zu erreichen und
von einer impfung auch zu überzeugen und
der zweite punkt den ich schon erwähnt
habe und denen auch vögel erwähnt habe
natürlich für diese eklatante
pflegenotstand und die kritische
situation gerade in der altenpflege dazu
dass basis hygienemaßnahmen nicht
eingreifen denn als wirklich
grundsätzliche sachen und wenn es daran
scheitert dann müssen wir glaube ich
über andere maßnahmen erst mal nicht
reden wir sollten ja also sozusagen
erstmal wirklich bei den sehr
naheliegenden sachen anfangen also hier
braucht es sicherlich auf eine große
unterstützung im pflegebereich sie sagen
ja dass es jetzt gut koordiniert werden
dass boost dann das ersten das eben auch
die richtigen dann geimpft werden
eigentlich dürfte das ja was die
koordinierung angeht keine so große kann
dieser großen probleme bereiten denn
wenn ich das so richtig im kopf habe
dann haben wir ja impfstoff in hülle und
fülle bei uns dann müsste das buch dann
doch relativ schnell von der hand gehen
ja natürlich aber trotzdem ist es eine
große herausforderung der sprechen hier
von knapp 20 millionen menschen wenn wir
eben die pflegekräfte hinzuziehen und
vor allen dingen auch angehörige wir
vergessen oftmals eben grad im teil der
ambulanten pflege die durch
familienangehörige durchgeführt wird das
ist auch noch mal ein großer bereich und
auch dort sind teste eben sehr sehr
hilfreich um einträge eben zu den
wohlhabenden zu verhindern also es ist
keine einfache aufgabe und darum ist es
ihm gerade wichtig nicht zu sagen lasst
euch jetzt alle boostern das führt zu
einem absoluten chaos in den praxen zu
einen ansturm der am schnellsten laufen
kann bekommt dann die termine damit ist
uns jetzt gerade nicht geholfen wir
müssen wirklich erst mal sowie die stiko
das empfohlen haben priorisieren und so
schnell wie es geht in die besonders
gefährdeten auffrischen wer koordiniert
das denn eigentlich dann oder sollte es
koordinieren sind ja impfzentren
geschlossen worden jetzt sollen sie
wieder geöffnet werden die hausärzte
sagen die können wir ja nicht alle auf
einmal versorgen wie soll das von der
koordination
funktionieren denn wir erinnern uns hier
an den letzten winter da hat das nicht
besonders gut geklappt dann anfangen
das ist eine sehr komplexe frage wo sie
natürlich auch mit den entsprechenden
vertretern der kbv und so weiter
sprechen wir aber wir sehen eben große
unterschiede zwischen den bundesländern
in schleswig holstein ist das
hervorragend gemacht worden dass ein
großteil sozusagen wir die die
auffrischimpfung benötigen bereits
aufgefrischt in anderen ländern sieht
das anders aus sie sehen hier es gibt
hier wie im pandemie geschehen und auch
bei der im sport und auch bei den
booster impfungen sehr sehr große
unterschiede also komplexität dass wir
gleich wieder bei der politik sie haben
gerade auch schon gesagt also ein
herrscht eigentlich ein heilloses
durcheinander
es gibt noch eine alte regel die
pandemische notlage die läuft jetzt aus
am 25 november dann weiß man aber nicht
so genau wie das gesetz im einzelnen
aussieht da gibt es dann so begriffe wie
3g das heißt also man kommt nur noch zu
bestimmten veranstaltungen oder in
bestimmte institutionen wenn man geimpft
genießen oder getestet ist zweig da wird
das testen wegfallen nur noch wer
geimpft und
genießen ist ein ski wird auch schon
gefördert dass nämlich alle sich testen
lassen müssen wenn das jetzt sozusagen
jetzt ständig die welt hinausposaunt
wird wie man es geht um die bekämpfung
dieser führten
und wenn jeder was anderes macht was
bedeutet dass das macht das eigentlich
auch mit den menschen die eigentlich
jetzt auf hilfe hoffen oder von der
politik erwarten macht endlich das damit
wir diese pandemie in den griff kriegen
also bei dem gesetz ist es so dass den
ländern grundsätzlich die mittel an die
hand gegeben werden sollen dass sie
immer noch schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen
können allerdings was eben nicht mehr
geht das was zum beispiel drosten
fordert dass das man möglicherweise
punktuell auch noch mal einen richtigen
lockdown macht das geht tatsächlich mit
dem gesetzlich das geht nur mit der
pandemischen notlage die jetzt offiziell
beendet wird was die länder dann aber
noch machen können ist masken pflicht
anordnen und eben abstandsregeln und
siege länder können auch individuell
entscheiden ob sie 2g oder 3g machen das
ist eben das ist also noch möglich und
dann nebenbei werden ja noch
verschiedene verordnungen diskutiert
unter anderem was jetzt kommen soll was
heute angekündigt wurde dass einmal in
der woche jeder bürger einen test
kostenfrei dann doch wieder kostenfrei
bekommen kann und eben auch der umgang
noch mit anderen dingen soll dann noch
in weiteren verordnungen geändert
geändert werden und dann hat man auch
noch einige finanzielle hilfen
verlängert die in der pandemie gezahlt
wurden das heißt man verlängert die
pandemische notlage quasi mit krücken
also man sagt wie man sagt 'die ist zu
ende was eigentlich quatsch das was nur
die einlösung über ein noch nie so groß
diät ja das ist ja das was ich gerade
gesagt hat sie sind auf einen erneuten
höhepunkt und sagen die notlage ist zu
ende natürlich kann man nicht
beschließen dass eine solche notlage zu
ende ist das ist dem virus relativ egal
und das führt bei den leuten natürlich
dazu dass sie die politik dann auch
nicht mehr so richtig ernst nehmen und
das auch das was von den menschen
gefordert wird nämlich dieses abstand
halten und so weiter nicht mehr ernst
genommen wird und es gibt natürlich auch
eine gewisse müdigkeit bei den leuten
die sich bisher immer schön an alle
regeln gehalten haben sich zweimal
impfen lassen und auch bereit wären sich
vielleicht ein drittes mal impfen zu
lassen und dann sehen das aber doch ein
ungefähr ein drittel der gesellschaft
sich daraus verabschiedet rechts und
auch nur recht ist auch ein fünftel der
gesellschaft aber die verabschieden sich
da raus und sagen wir machen da nicht
mit und nehmen so die anderen die sich
eigentlich die regeln halten und mit
ihrem verhalten auch wirklich gut die
pandemie bekämpfen seien so mehr oder
weniger in geiselhaft und es wird ja
auch jetzt schon gesprochen über 2g plus
also dass man geimpft und genesen ist
und sich trotzdem testen lässt das sind
dann also alles so erschwernisse die für
die leute hinzu kommen die eigentlich
bisher alles richtig gemacht haben und
die politik mit ihren ganz
unterschiedlichen signalen und auch
dieser vor allen dingen unklarheit wer
eigentlich im moment verantwortung trägt
also die geschäftsführende
bundesregierung ist es nicht mehr weil
die muss er jetzt nach der flöte der
neuen mehrheiten im bundestag tanzen und
kanzler scholz bisher noch kein einziges
wort also künftige kanzler scholz ja
bisher noch kein einziges wort zu dieser
pandemie und das sorgt dafür dass sich
auch die leute allein gelassen fühlen
was ist denn in diesem hochsensiblen
bereich pflege für sie jetzt im moment
dass die politik da gerade diskutiert
besonders wichtig ist es 3g ist es also
das heißt tests sind auch noch dann
erlaubt als zugangsberechtigung es ist
zweig also nur noch die geimpften nur
noch die genesenen
gibt glaube ich wenn ich denn man muss
ja immer gucken dass man auf dem
neuesten stand der dinge ist wenn ich es
richtig sehe was die politik jetzt
vorher die ampel koalition dann hat man
sich noch nicht mal auf eine testpflicht
in heimen geeinigt da sollte man jetzt
will man die rechtliche grundlage oder
die rechtliche sicherheit überprüfen was
ist aus ihrer sicht eigentlich da das
sinnvollste was wäre das sinnvollste um
gerade in diesem hochsensiblen bereichen
die ansteckungsgefahr zu reduzieren wir
müssen alles tun um die wohlhabenden
gruppen zu schützen und das heißt
wirklich also die haben's ja gemerkt in
berlin zum beispiel gibt es die
testpflicht für die ungeimpften
mitarbeitenden in den pflegeheimen
während in berlin noch keinen ausbruch
in brandenburg ist passiert da gibt es
diese tests nicht eben dich also und
genau da beginnt es wir müssen täglich
testen
damit wir die bewohnerinnen in den
heimen schützen aber auch in den
kliniken natürlich wir müssen nach wie
vor habe ich auch noch dabei
wir haben nachdem nach der situation
deutschland krempelt die ärmel hoch
haben wir nichts keine kampagnen mehr
gehabt wir haben keine aufklärung
situation gehabt wir haben nicht erlebt
dass zielgruppenspezifisch in die
bestimmten bereiche gegangen wurde zu
den menschen gegangen wurde ich glaube
wir brauchen noch mehr busse die durch
die gegend fahren und immer ganz ganz
niedrigschwellig anbieten in allen
bereichen für die heime bedeutet wir
haben heute mittag gerade diskutiert
dass wir sagen gehen wir auf die 2g
regelung was wir tatsächlich aber auch
wirklich nicht mehr dürfen ist dass wir
angehörige fernhalten von ihm von den
patientinnen und patienten und von den
bewohnerinnen dass ihre erfahrung
schläft die politik mal wieder
es ist wenn man wenn man zum beispiel in
pflegeheime betreibt dann brauche ich
tatsächlich eine ganz klare politische
aussage was jetzt eine regel ist sonst
kann ich zum beispiel gar nicht nach
kann ich meine mitarbeitenden befragen
wie kann ich das arbeitsrechtlich
bestimmte dinge umsetzen was ist denn
mit mitarbeitenden die nicht geimpften
stelle ich die dann freiwillig eine
zweig regelungen bekomme all diese dinge
müssen ja dann auch geklärt werden die
sind tatsächlich nicht geklärt und
werden momentan noch in der
verantwortung derjenigen der diedesfeld
quasi bestellen gelassen und ganz oft
gibt es da große unsicherheiten und von
bundesland zu bundesland unterschiedlich
wir haben ja auch träger die sind zum
beispiel über die bundesländer verteilt
die am unterschiedlichste
vorgehensweisen in den bundesländern und
da wird es dann auch deutlich wie
schwierig und komplex es eigentlich ist
zum beispiel wirklich
gesundheitsversorgung heute auch im
ambulanten bereich zu managen und so
bleibt es wirklich der kompetenz der
pflegenden und der gesundheits dem
entscheiden die politik wenn es da
gewissermaßen auch verantwortung gehabt
also aus unserer sicht ein unglaublich
viel es gibt ein paar
unterstützungsangebote aber es ist sehr
wirklich sehr länder unterschiedlich
herr professor peter lotzer am 25
november ich habe es vorhin schon
erwähnt läuft ja die so genannte
epigenetische notlage von nationaler
tragweite
auswahl denn diese bisherige notlage die
ja von der alten bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten
noch verabschiedet und durchgeführt
worden ist war das denn eine so
unzumutbare einschränkung von
grundrechten die pflicht zu masken
tragen abstandsgebot kontaktverbot auch
betriebsschließungen aufgrund von lockt
von maßnahmen waren diese
notlage eine so unzumutbare
einschränkung der grundrechte
wird es ich überhaupt nicht so man kann
sogar fragen umgekehrt fragen ob das
nicht zu wenig weit ging und zu wenig
strict war und zu viel variationen
erlaubte und der gang der epidemie zeit
scheint es ja auch zu bestätigen und
dass man jetzt
sie abschaffen will das ist ein
armutszeugnis
des bundes
der in der hauptverantwortung steht und
jetzt wo corona ungeahnte ausmaße wieder
annimmt eine solche regelung
abzuschaffen ist geradezu grotesk
das passt überhaupt nicht in die
situation ich habe keinerlei verständnis
dafür das ist allerdings nicht nur auf
den beeten der kommenden koalition
gewachsen sondern schon der
geschäftsführende gesundheitsminister
der der isar koalition nicht angehören
wird er hat ja gesagt das solle
auslaufen werden nicht erneuert und auf
die fragen wie sieht es verträgt mit der
verschärfung der pandemischen situation
wusste er keine wirkliche antwort zu
geben das ist unverantwortlich das
darf nicht sein und ich hoffe sehr dass
die politischen kräfte sich da besinnen
und verantwortung übernehmen übrigens
ich bin sehr dafür dass der bund diese
regelungen verstärkt an sich zieht und
bei sich behält was nicht bedeutet dass
diese regelung
ungeachtet der inzidenz und so weiter in
gleicher weise in einen bundesländern
gelten müssen aber er muss das
instrumentarium das kann ja auch vorhin
schon an was gesagt wurde er muss das
instrumentarium bereitstellen und wenn
die lage so und so ist auch regional
verschieden dann müssen die jeweils
verantwortlichen auf auch die lokalen
behörden eben davon gebrauch machen
können aber den rahmen dafür hat
gefälligst der bund
aufzustellen und zu setzen und dann muss
es trägt er sein bisher und wie ich
vorhin schon angedeutet habe
zu diesem rahmen gehört heute auch
angesichts der offenbaren impfmüdigkeit
das für den äußersten notfall eben eine
begrenzte oder allgemeine impfpflicht
auf vorrat gehalten wird die dann
abgerufen werden kann sei es durch eine
feststellung des bundestages oder was
ich besser fände durch eine gemeinsame
erklärung des bundestages und des
bundesrates nicht durch ein gesetz
sondern durch einen gemeinsamen
beschluss auf der grundlage des bereits
geltenden gesetzes der besagt jetzt muss
die impfpflicht eingeführt werden aber
der bund gibt keine anzeichen von sich
dass sie diese verhandlung gerecht wird
schmidt chanasit wäre eine impfpflicht
wie sie professor pestalozzi jetzt
gerade skizziert hat er die aus der
sicht des virologen aus der sicht ihrer
erfahrung auch mit diesen knapp zwei
jahren kroner pandemie das
kontraproduktiv oder wird er es an
bestimmten stellen vielleicht sogar
helfen
das ist natürlich eigentlich keine frage
von virologen sollen rechtlich noch mal
die frage aber natürlich werde ich damit
sozusagen im foto erhöhen wäre das
natürlich wünschenswert aber sonst ja
noch mal es ist einfach
sagen dass die umgegend schuld wären
etwas relativiert die amis dorf ein
bisschen komplexer und einfahrten sind
dann natürlich war falsch wir haben
durchaus deutliche unterschiede bei der
impfquote in hamburg zum beispiel wenn
wir die über 18-jährigen anschauen und
dann vor einige genesenen mit dazu
berechnen was ganz wichtig ist dann
kommen wir auf knapp 90 prozent
und dann fragt man sich natürlich die
frage ich am anfang gestellt habe wien
kann man denn überhaupt noch erreichen
mit den impfungen natürlich gibt es
menschen aber es gibt auch impfgegner
und impfgegner wird man auch mit einer
impfpflicht meines erachtens nicht
überzeugen also wie wollen sie das
machen aber natürlich wenn man sich die
frage noch mal vor augen führt wünsche
ich mir sehr dass wir so viele menschen
impfen ließ ebene möglich ist aber ich
bezweifele eben dass wir mit dies mit
mehr druck erreichen werden das zeigen
repräsentative umfrage auch kostenlos
studie auch eine studie die in hamburg
durchgeführt wurde insofern bin ich da
vollkommen bei vor vogler wir müssen die
zielgruppen besser erreichen mobile
angebote mit vertrauenspersonen es
werden keine deutschen medien konsumiert
insofern das muss man alles
berücksichtigen will man diese
impflücken schießen will das ist sehr
sehr aufwendig sie sagen ja dass die
haushälften bei ihnen glaube ich im
pflegebereich da diejenigen sind
mitnehmen da auch überzeugungsarbeit
leisten muss wo auch nicht die einsicht
da ist dass man sich impfen lassen muss
hat das immer eine meine
herkunftsgeschichte eine
migrationsgeschichte oder dass auch noch
andere gründe die frage wäre ja wenn da
so viele sich weigern in einem so
sensiblen bereich ob eine impfpflicht da
helfen würde ich weiß kann also erst mal
würde ich gar nicht nur auf die
helfenden sondern wir haben wir wissen
es ja nicht nur wir wissen nur wir haben
ausbrüche wir wissen auch nicht nicht
immer woher die ausbrüche kommen
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass wir
feststellen dass in den langzeit
einrichtungen manchmal wirklich
tatsächlich weniger geimpft sind ich
glaube wirklich hatte vor zwei wochen
mit kolleginnen die auch verantwortung
für pflegeheime tragen also mit leitung
die wirklich alle register ziehen um
auch überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten um zu
unterstützen um auch diejenigen die
sorgen haben ja auch in kliniken gibt es
pflegende die sich nicht im plan gibt es
aber auch ärzte die sich nicht
irgendwann gibt es auch reinigungskräfte
die sich nicht impfen lassen die haben
hier viele menschen die in den
einrichtungen arbeiten und genau da eben
noch mal angebote zu machen und zu sagen
und zu fragen hin zu hören zu fahren was
ist denn deine sorge warum du dich nicht
impfen lässt und darauf einzugehen ich
glaube das haben wir das noch mal ein
bisschen versäumt in den letzten monaten
das hätten wir noch machen müssen es
wird immer welche geben die wir nicht
erreichen und zum thema impfzwang wir
haben als deutsche pflegerat gesagt dass
wir auch ein impfzwang der wird uns
nicht zum ziel führen und deswegen ist
es wirklich noch mal ganz wichtig an die
berufsgruppen im gesundheitswesen zu
appellieren lasst euch impfen das ist
unglaublich wichtig und auch wirklich
wenn wir über ins situation die 2g
nachdenken oder andere dinge dass man
sie einrichtungs bezogen ausspricht
und gleichzeitig darüber nachdenkt wie
machen wir besucher und angehörigen
management in frankreich in italien gibt
es aber eine impfung sei jetzt wahr ist
auch immer ein
impfzwang klingt schon nach weniger
sympathisch in frankreich italien gibt
es tatsächlich eine impfpflicht im
pflegebereich mit dem ergebnis die
bevölkerung die ja auch aus ihrer
richtung auskommen dann wird man so und
so viele kündigten dass das im
promillebereich war die leute die da
dann abgezogen sind die dass die
deswegen nicht weiter arbeiten wollten
eigentlich haben diese beiden länder die
ja ähnliche probleme mit der pandemie
haben wie wir ja mit der impfpflicht in
diesem bereich gute erfahrungen gemacht
ich kann es ist glaskugel leser ich kann
sie nicht sagen ob die menschen gehen
oder nicht ich
ich wünschte mir manchmal aber
vielleicht ist es ja auch in formaten
wunsch dass wir in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft ist anders hinkriegen als
über zwar
im pflicht sagen es ist ja
interessanterweise zum ersten märz 2020
ist er die masern in pflicht gesetz
geworden und die ist auch über jahre
sehr strittig in der öffentlichkeit
diskutiert wurden drei
gesundheitsminister haben sich daran
abgearbeitet und einer hat es dann
eingeführt und es ist erstaunlich
geräuschlos über die bühne gegangen es
müssen sich lehrkräfte müssen und
medizinisches personal und alle ab 1970
geborenen und eben alle schulkinder
müssen sich gegen masern impfen lassen
und das auch nachweisen und ich habe von
keinen kündigungen gehört von lehrern
und auch nicht aus dem pflegebereich
korrigieren sie mich gerne wenn auch
wenn es damals in haft abwanderung
gegeben hätte wegen masern impfung das
ist akzeptiert worden also ich gebe
ihnen recht dass es besser wäre wenn man
die leute anders erreichen würde und das
was in einer demokratie in einer freien
gesellschaft auch sinnvoll ist aber bei
den masern hat man es nicht geschafft
und man hat es dann über diesen hebel
impfpflicht tatsächlich geschafft wir
haben das problem aus der welt es gibt
diese großen masernausbrüche in den
schulen nicht mehr
keine impfpflicht bei masern über die
gesamte bevölkerung die haben wir nicht
sondern
sieben bereichen ich weiß jetzt diese
frage als unterstellung empfinden aber
sind sie vielleicht auch deswegen gegen
die impfpflicht weil sie damit natürlich
riesenprobleme in ihrem sektor in ihrer
branche bekämen weil dann viele sagen
nee ich lasse mich nicht impfen und dann
wird ja quasi wieder die die ganze der
ganze konflikt auf die auf die unterste
ebene verlagert auf
die versorgungsebenen wirklich nennen
und ich
wir sind nicht wir sind für eine
impfpflicht wenn das alle betrifft wir
sind für eine impfpflicht einrichtungs
bezogen das sagen wir immer wieder
und tatsächlich ist es so ein bisschen
unterstellung es wird es schwingt immer
so ein bisschen mit so schuldige zu
suchen in dieser pandemischen situation
aber darum kann es dauern kann ich gar
nicht gehen schon liegt nun sind ja wenn
dann ungeimpfte die sich bewusst nicht
impfen lassen aber nicht
pflegebereich tung oder oder
berufsgruppe die sozusagen so ein
bisschen mitschwingen ich das personal
das sich nicht besonders viel größere
gruppe die sagt will ich nicht deswegen
noch mal einrichtungs bezogen ist das
unproblematisch da sind wir bei der
masernimpfung aber wenn wir aber ich
glaube bei der masernimpfung gibt es
eine impfung und dann noch eine zweite
und wir sind in einer situation wo wir
gar nicht die auswirkungen kennen aber
dafür steige ich mich da ist unser
virologe viel sicherer als ich ich kann
nur sagen dass wir operativ
an den orten wo wir pflege ausüben alles
dafür tun dass die menschen gesund
bleiben mit allem was ist und deswegen
auch unsere haltung wenn wir brauchen
regeln die die politik uns geben muss
und zwar deutlich und da hoffe ich dass
die politik den virologen folgt mit den
empfehlungen die wir seit monaten seit
einigen monaten kennen und hören und da
wird es dann für uns dann auch langsam
unverständlich weil wir wirklich
unterschiedlichste
voraussetzungen in den bundesländern
haben in der versorgung haben ich habe
jetzt mit einrichtungen wieder gehabt
die kriegen wieder momentan keine tests
kids einfach wir haben wir sind so viele
operative kleinigkeiten die wir machen
die wir haben da gibt es einige länder
da kann man den impfstatus nicht
abfragen es gibt andere länder da ist es
möglich also da ist noch ein bisschen
was zu tun geködert die frage an den
virologen gleich weiterreichen schmidt
chanasit
lässt sich die masern
und corona nicht vergleichen auch sich
in der komplexität auch wegen der
schieren zahl der betroffenen
wenn wir jetzt über eine
berufsspezifische impfpflicht sprechen
kann man natürlich dort unterschiede
definieren die manning von kennen wir
seit jahrzehnten wir haben eine
lebenslange immunität einen sehr hohen
schutz das ist jetzt bei der krone virus
impfen eben anders das ist natürlich
kein grund sich nicht impfen zu lassen
aber das wird natürlich durchaus auch
als argument benutzt von den menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen dadurch
dass wir keine impfpflicht haaren kann
man eben nur durch diskussionen und
nochmal darlegung der fakten und
begründen warum die impfung diesen
bereichen so wichtig ist natürlich
darauf drängen dass sich diese menschen
impfen das aber nochmal ich glaube bei
den begrenzten ressourcen die wir haben
und wenn sie jetzt entscheiden wissen wo
schicken sie 100 mobile impfen ich
schicke ich würde diese mobilen im teams
dorthin schicken wo sie jetzt in diese
booster impfung durchführen können weil
ich eben sehe das ist eine unheimlich
herausforderung kraftanstrengung ist
impfgegner zu überzeugen oder eben die
vielleicht doch eher wenigen im
skeptiker die es noch gibt obwohl das
natürlich eine wichtige aufgabe ist aber
es geht um effizienz in der akademie das
ist das entscheidende
effizienz wenn die impfquote nicht
weiter steigt diese so genannte
herdenimmunität doch nicht erreicht wird
also eine impfpflicht wieder ins spiel
kommen zumindest die politische
diskussion war es da so
sinnreich dass nahezu alle politiker
jetzt während der pandemie gesagt haben
also eine impfpflicht kommt auf keinen
fall also das hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister gesagt das hat
die bundeskanzlerin gesagt der
bayerische ministerpräsident auch eine
ganze reihe von sozialdemokratischen
politikern also eine impfpflicht kommt
nicht verspreche ich ihnen wir bleiben
bei unserem versprechen kommt nicht
endlich kommt auf keinen fall in frage
wer das von vorneherein so ausschließt
entweder
würde er seinen politischen
handlungsspielraum erheblich verengen
oder er muss wortbrüchig werden war das
so klug von der politik das von
vorneherein auszuschließen
weil man angst hat die leute fühlen sich
bevormundet in ihrem freiheitsdrang
ich bin ja immer gemerkt die politik
wirklich an einstellen dann auch
entsprechend kritisch zu behandeln aber
in dem fall
hat man das gesagt mit der impfpflicht
auch um weil man davon ausgegangen ist
dass sich eine große mehrheit also dass
es reichen wird es ist für die herde
nicht reichen wird wenn der impfstoff
erst immer da ist also das war
tatsächlich die zu optimistische annahme
und man hätte wahrscheinlich auch das
vertrauen in diesen impfstoff dezimiert
wenn man gesagt hätte und wenn ihr euch
nicht impfen lassen dann kommt die
impfpflicht das wäre sicherlich auch das
falsche signal gewesen und ich sehe auch
noch nicht dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kommen dass sie da
wortbrüchig werden ich sehe aber dass
man sehr wohl über impfpflicht für
berufsgruppen und eben medizinisches
personal und auch in die schulen
regelung schule und kita sind auf jeden
fall nachdenken muss beziehungsweise das
sehe ich dass das durchaus kommen kann
und das wäre dann an der stelle noch
kein wortbruch aber die politik ist da
im moment sehr hasenfüßig also
beispielsweise die grünen-chefin berbalk
die hat sich im wahlkampf noch getraut
zu sagen wenn die lage schlimmer wird
müssen wir das ernsthaft diskutieren und
inzwischen spricht da keiner mehr von
also wir sind im moment relativ weit weg
davon ich habe das gefühl dass sie sogar
noch hasen für sieger geworden ist als
im bisherigen verlauf der pandemie ist
das der richtige eindruck dass man
eigentlich dieses thema am liebsten von
sich schieben würde weil man damit
eigentlich keine lorbeeren gewinnen
können ja und die haben natürlich im
moment noch ganz andere sorgen die
wollen nämlich zusammen eine ampel
koalition schmieden bei der sie bei den
verhandlungen auch noch nicht weit genug
sind und dann kommt das corona problem
nach oben drauf es ist auch tatsächlich
schwer im moment all das was aufgelöst
und beschlossen werden muss unter einen
hut zu bringen und das ist auch der
grund warum uns die pandemie gerade
wieder davon galoppiert weil die politik
überhaupt nicht den blick und den sinn
dafür hatte sich auf jesus eine wirklich
zentrale problem zurich langer zeit wenn
man schon bei kroner nicht einig wird
oder keine konsistente in sich
schlüssige politik politisches angebot
machen kann wie sieht das dann erst aus
bei
beim migration bei bei klima weil
staatsfinanzen klima migration
staatsfinanzen haben sie genau die drei
punkte genannt an denen es ganz schön
hart und von denen ich vermute dass sie
auch dafür sorgen werden dass die
koalitionsverhandlungen ein bisschen
länger dauern als gewünscht herr
professor christa nutzer was lehrt uns
eigentlich die geschichte der
impfpflicht in deutschland denn die gab
es ja schon mal also ich bin jahrgang
1960 wurde als kleinkind geimpft gegen
keuchhusten
gegen kinderlähmung gegen pocken und
gegen die story diese diese impfung
wurde sogar noch mal in der schule dann
mit 13 jahren aufgefrischt das war eine
impfpflicht wir haben es mit der
impfpflicht geschafft die pocken und die
kinderlähmung fast aus unseren lebten zu
verbannen was lehrt uns diese geschichte
der impfpflicht kann man davon ausgehen
dass sie auch wenn sie denn eingeführt
wird die krone pandemie weitgehend
wieder aus unserem leben verbannt oder
ist das eine illusion
dass die von ihnen erwähnte pocken
schutzimpfung ist ein gutes beispiel
wir haben dafür ein gesetz gehabt dass
ungefähr etwas über 100 jahre gegolten
hat und dass man dann abgeschafft hat
als mal gesagt hat es gibt keine puppen
mehr und wir brauchen keine pflicht im
funk mehr dafür das hat also offenbar
gewirkt und zwar ohne großes aufhebens
das galt über generationen hinweg bis es
eben soweit war dass man sagen konnte
diesen schutz im pflicht auch wenn nicht
mehr das hat endlich gezeigt dass das
ganz gut geht und auch von der deutschen
bevölkerung gut bewältigt wird
und
diese
zitierten worte der politik mit uns gibt
es eine impfpflicht nicht die sind grob
fahrlässig wie kann man so etwas in die
welt setzen wer wer skeptisch
wer von den skeptikern gegenüber der
eine impfung wird sich überzeugen lassen
er soll zur impfung gehen wenn die
politik sagte es wird schon nicht so
schlimm werden so dass wir keine
impfpflicht brauchen das spielt die
bedeutung der pandemie stark herunter
also das fand ich unklug und wenn man
dieses wort brechen würde
frau eine formulierung von frau quadbeck
aufzunehmen dann wäre ich sehr froh wenn
man sagt wir wollen sich jetzt noch
nicht haben und jeder jurist weiß auch
das ist das allerletzte mittel wenn
alles andere nicht hilft und die dinge
noch schlimmer werden dazu gibt es einen
vierfachen verhältnismäßigkeit test.de
nicht im einzelnen ja nicht entfalten
muss da können sie sicher sein dass das
nicht übers knie gebrochen wird aber man
muss darauf vorbereitet sein dass wir
kein anderes wirksames mittel mehr haben
da muss man zur pflicht greifen und dann
darf man nicht beginnen sie zu
entwickeln und rechtlich zu formulieren
sondern das instrumentarium muss in der
schublade liegen als fertiges gesetz und
sofort angewendet werden können da ist
die politik zum handeln verpflichtet
auch wenn die impfpflicht vielleicht
noch nicht aktuell werden sollte was sie
leider nicht danach aus mannschaft ja
wie gesagt mit worten die pandemische
lager ab national
realität sieht ganz anders aus und haben
wir einen aspekt vielleicht wenn ich das
noch
erleben werde ich alleine weder in
berlin noch in hamburg noch in
deutschland insgesamt
leben inmitten einer ziemlich eng
bevölkerten welt und haben verantwortung
auch gegenüber unseren nachbarn
angesichts der mobilität zwischen all
den ländern es ist verantwortungslos
wenn wir nicht wenigstens in unserem
bereich dafür sorgen dass zu versuchen
eine hohe impfquote zu erreichen und
bewohner wirklich ein zudem wenigstens
in unserem gebiet gut ich habe noch eine
frage und leider noch 30 sekunden aber
vielleicht fällt jemandem etwas einen
westen freiheit da haben wir ja viel
über freiheit heute gesprochen ist
eigentlich bedroht die der ungeimpften
durch die impfpflicht oder die dagegen
durch das virus ist die freiheit aller
bedroht haben bin ich bei ihnen
schmidt chanasit
erstens freiheit ist
gut dann können wir damit die sendung
beschließen ich bedanke mich bei eva
quadbeck bei christine kugler bei jonas
schmidt-chanasit und bei christian
pestalozza liebe zuschauer morgen kommt
hier auf diesem sendeplatz die
diskussionsrunde blühende landschaften
energiewende in ostdeutschland im rahmen
der ard-themenwoche
stadland wandel morgen um 22 uhr 15
jetzt folgt für nix der tag mit stephan
kulle darin unter anderem die situation
der flüchtlinge an der grenze von
belarus und polen bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]